I'd feel like you're someone who gets  pitched a lot yes so I got you the  things that you look for every day I get  a hundred emails that say I'll help you  buy the New York Jets I never even open  them somebody hits me up about a very  small Nuance of how He-Man built their  IP in 1986 right now I'll reply to them  let alone open it because right now I'm  building the ipv friends and that hits  right scaled Outreach email and DM  everyone on earth that could Grant make  it contextual to them that will take you  a lot of time homework to get in there  follow every single decision maker to a  grant on Twitter look at your stream  somebody says something about Friends  the TV show about steak dinners around  skiing and you've got something to  contribute to it reply with it that's  value not high not I agree because  they're not going to notice Relentless  context